Hello everyone.
All right. Yeah, I was like, this is after lunch,
so, you know.
Um How many of you
are in a
product owner,
product, you know, manager
roles? Can I get a show of hands, please?
All right.
And how many of you are in,
say, engineering roles?
Got it. We've got a good mix here.
So this story would sound familiar.
Let's say you're a product owner
and
You wanted to make
Your end users.
Or you want to empower your end users with
data-driven decisions.
You pull a bunch of metrics,
go to your engineering teams.
Engineering team
builds an awesome dashboard using some visualization
libraries.
You launch it to your users,
wow, they love it.
But then
they ask for more.
Hey, Can
I get you to add the year over year
metrics also? Can I get you to
add Churn?
Can I bring my own data?
Can I just talk to the data?
I don't want to bug you
Hi. My name is Shekhar Kopuri.
I am one of the leaders.
Managing product in
QuickSweet.
And
I built
And run with Quicksight,
which is the business intelligence and analytics
capabilities
within QuickSuite.
And today,
With my colleague Jose,
we're gonna show you
how you can extract value.
Out of Quicksight
by using it in embedded modes.
We also have our esteemed guest, Kirtan
from Moody's, who's gonna walk you through
a successful embedding implementation
of Quicksight.
So, we're gonna talk about some capabilities
We're going to talk about
What you can do by
using Quicksight in embedded uh embedded
setting. Caton's journey
And then we are also going to touch upon some of the
new capabilities that we launched literally
8 weeks ago
in Amazon Quick Quick Set.
Yeah, the tongue twisters keep going happening.
So what is Amazon Quick Seed?
It is
AI native agentic
platform.
That allows you to unify
all of your data,
structured and unstructured,
your entire enterprise's
corpus of knowledge
into a single space.
It then allows you to
extract insights from it.
And then translates those insights.
Into actions
and all within the framework
of
governance.
Security,
observability,
because it lets you then.
Understand the business value you're extracting.
Out of the platform
Quicksight.
Is
a unified BI.
Experience,
set of capabilities
within Quick Sweet.
Where you can build interactive dashboards.
Or pixel perfect reports, or even
have conversational analytics.
To build dashboards,
you can connect.
All your traditional data sources, be
it,
you know, relational databases,
data lakes,
And then you can use AI to author
these dashboards,
whether
to
create new visuals, format visuals,
or say even create calculated fields
because you don't have to worry about remembering the syntax.
We have integrated
Hichhart score library into Quicksight.
That lets your users build a host
of advanced visualizations.
that are not only
Engaging
But really beautiful.
You can also
build pixel-perfect reports
with Quicksight.
With this,
You can push
business critical information
directly to your end users' inboxes.
These reports could be PDFs, Excels,
or CSVs.
And The entire framework
is built on the cloud,
which means that you don't have to manage
servers or installations, which is typical
to reporting.
You can also
Use
conversational analytics.
On the entire data, not just the structure
data, so
imagine
you have.
The traditional data,
along with knowledge bases, wiki
pages,
emails,
all of that context together.
And then,
in natural language query, you can ask
questions and get instantaneous answers
with the full context.
Quicksight and Quick Suite
is built
as cloud native,
serverless architecture.
Which means
that you don't have to manage.
Or host
any servers.
You don't have to deal with.
Hardware upgrades
You don't have to deal with OS patches or
software upgrades.
And with our pay per use,
flexible pricing.
You are not tied in any multiyear
software contracts either.
So To
understand the economics of quick sight.
There was a recent survey done by an
independent third party group.
It's called Enterprise Strategy Group,
and they. Surveyed
customers.
who moved on to Quicksight
from comparative
BI workloads.
And found that over 3 years of usage,
Their costs reduced by 67%.
But more importantly,
the user engagement went
all the way,
in some cases up to 300%
and a model ROI of over 300%
in 3 years.
So we set out,
when we are building Quick site.
To build a platform on the cloud.
So that we can
provide insights to everyone.
One of the key ways
we do that today
is by opening Quicksight's
capabilities.
For embedding.
What we are seeing with our customers.
Is that the embedding setup is
being used by both enterprises
and independent software vendors alike.
Enterprises are using.
The embedding setting.
To deploy BI capabilities
in exactly where their users
are operating in
for doing their day to day jobs.
So if it's an HR specialist,
it's in the HR tool. If it's a
marketing specialist, it's in a marketing
tool, right? If it's a sales
specialist, it's in the sales tool.
And ISPs are supercharging
their products
by embedding analytics into
their offering
and With
that, they see
higher customer satisfaction,
better engagement,
and higher retention rates.
In fact,
today, there are thousands of
products
that are being powered
by Quicksight in the market.
These range for, from products,
from small startups to really
uh uh established large enterprises
where 10
and thousands of users are using
Quicksight capabilities within one account
in an embedding setting.
There are
enterprises that are operating with.
You know, scores of business units
or there are
Sas companies that are offering analytics
using Quicksight and deploying that
to thousands of tenants.
So what is that
all you can do with embedding in Quicksight?
We allow you to embed visuals for
high traffic pages.
You can deploy full page
analytics
using interactive dashboards.
You can also
embed
email reports.
You can either use Quicksight as the
authoring and generation engine.
Or you can use Quicksight as
a full.
Experience stack
where
the users schedule their reports
and even the delivery of the reports
happens from Quicksight.
Many products,
many product managers
have built
value-added
or
upsell capabilities
by introducing
full self-service authoring capabilities
using Quicksight in their products.
There are companies
who have.
Bought in data sets
using data prep.
There are companies who have allowed their
end users
to create their own custom dashboards from scratch
by supplying pre or pre-formatted
data sets.
And all of those possibilities
exist with self-service authoring.
You can also embed natural language queries-based
conversation analytics independently.
And our dashboards
with anonymous embedding,
you can deploy them even on public
websites. So
yes, we package
all the analytics capabilities
in all these modes.
But why should you consider
using Quicksight
to power your analytics in your enterprise
or in, in your uh
products? One
big reason is we are built for scale.
We can easily scale.
From
10 to 100s of thousands
of users.
Without you having to worry about that
scale.
A second big reason
is that we are enterprise ready.
With the right kind of governance mechanisms
in place.
With security features like
RLS and column-level
security, low-level security.
With Identity propagation
from AWS data leaks.
And with
fine-grained access control on all
of your assets.
You can be assured
That the user
only gets to see the data that
they're supposed to see.
We also support multiple identity integrations,
starting with AWS IM Identity
Center.
But you can also use
third-party IDPs, identity providers
like Octa and Ping
through SAML.
You can do
direct Native
Active Directory integration,
or if you're already on IM you can
just use IM Federation
to manage your identity.
If you have a need to deploy
assets into
Thousands of
Tenants
Then we offer flexibility on how you're
managing that architecture.
If your data is already fragmented
by a tenant or a business unit,
You can use the construct of name
spaces
to completely isolate the data, the
consumption layers, and your users in
a name space.
But there are many companies where that is
not the situation.
And the data is not fragmented
by the tenant upfront.
So you can use
RLS and CLS rules based on tags.
Or identities
To then manage.
The tendency,
but then the consumption layer, which is the
dashboards and reports that you create and
the users
can be isolated into name spaces.
Or
You can actually create individual stacks
all the way from the account level
for each.
Uh, tenant.
And then you can manage deployment across
all of that through APIs.
In fact,
we have a robust set of APIs.
And SDK
that allow you to do that.
Our embedding SDK.
I love you
To embed all of those experiences that
we talked about before.
And we offer things like one-click embedding,
which makes it very easy
for the engineering teams to integrate.
Quicksight into your products.
You can also connect
the interactions two ways.
Between your host application
and Quicksight
to things like
events that you're exposing on the SDK
or parameters that you can push down values
into Quicksight.
Our APIs
allow you to manage deployments at scale.
For workflows,
Like
moving assets from lower
environments to higher environments or
moving,
like building a dashboard in one
account and deploying it across thousands
of accounts.
Or managing your
users and your roles
and groups
through APIs.
You can do all of that
and make
the experience your own.
With custom branding,
And teeming
With brand
definitions,
you can define your brand colors, your
brand logos,
and that brand gets respected across
all of the consumption layers.
And with theming and custom branding
available dynamically
within. The embedding SDK
you can actually create one experience
and deploy it
in multiple variants.
As if they are multiple avatars.
Based on the user or the end
end customer
so that you don't have to rebuild the entire experience
over and over again.
So yes,
You can
Use Quicksight
In a way that you can power your
analytical needs
across multiple modalities.
But you don't
have to take
our word for that.
Companies like NFL are using
all of
the capabilities that I just talked
about. In improving
their fan engagement.
With
products like NextGen Stats.
Where they're able to push near real time
data
for every player and every play
directly to their fans.
They're using Quicksight
for a product called
Digital Athlete,
which improves player safety.
In NFL Combine.
They build dashboards.
So that your fans can.
Watch
and interact live
of what every player's speed
and strength is.
And they actually deployed that in NFL.com.
And with RBI acceleration engine,
We served that
entire experience flawlessly.
Even as fans were swarming to the
website. And
in NFL draft,
They built
A set of dashboards.
For every single NFL team.
And for the first time
in for NFL,
They built a conversational chat
called Draft IQ Assistant.
Where fans could just ask questions
and you'd get instantaneous answers
of what's happening.
They also use the chat agent
for actually building their content.
They integrated a bunch of
data into QuickSuite, Quicksight.
And then
their content creators started asking
questions. And got
sort of content summaries in about
10 to 20 seconds.
Previously, they would spend a couple of days
gathering all those pieces of information as
draft is happening
and build that.
All told,
The entire NFL combined
and NFL draft.
Uh
Experiences attracted
over a million
users, a million visitors.
And then there was insights that they
pushed.
To broadcast channels worldwide.
That is amazing,
how fast they could do all of
that with Quicksight's embedding
capabilities.
Now to walk you through another
successful customer journey,
let me invite Kirtan
from Moody's.
Thanks, Shekhar.
Uh. Hi,
my name is Kirtan Dave. I'm part of the product
management team at
Moody's Insurance Solution.
We recently launched a brand new
product called Risk Data Lake in which
we actually implemented all the
capabilities or most of the capabilities that Shaker
just walks, walked us through.
So we embedded Quicksight into the
application. To enable our clients
to build their own analytics. So in this section
I'll go over
some of the work that we did, more like what,
why, and how, what did we build, why
did we build it that way, and how did we build
it so that you get an idea
of how we approached this problem.
But before I go deep into this, let me first
give you guys an idea of what Moody's insurance
solution is. So if you're not familiar
with us, we are the market leader
in providing analytical solutions
to the insurance industry, property and casualty
insurance industry to help them
quantify catastrophic risk.
We provide models and solutions that help
the industry understand their exposure
to events like earthquakes and hurricanes
and other catastrophic events.
We provide such analytics throughout
the risk life cycle. So if you think about
the journey of
insurance risk, it starts from primary underwriting
where the risk is getting underwritten
for the very first time all the way to reinsurance
and brokers and other players in
between. And at every step of
the way, every entity is
trying to really understand what their
exposure is to catastrophic
events like earthquake and hurricane.
We deliver all these analytics
using persona centric applications. Some of the
names you see in there risk modeler,
Treaty IQ, And IQ, exposure IQ
are persona centric applications that
are built
to deliver that analytics
to our end users,
and these
applications are built on a platform
that we call intelligent Disk platform.
This platform provides infrastructure
and core set of services that these
applications take advantage of.
This platform and all these applications are
built on AWS technology
and we are the first and the only provider
of the cloud native platform and
applications spanning the entire risk life
cycle
covering catastrophic modeling needs for
the property and casualty insurance.
Today we have over 100s of clients
using the platform and one or more
applications on the platform.
When we look at our clients' teams that are
working on the platform,
they consist of obviously the business users
in this example,
Jane, who could be an underwriter or
a portfolio manager.
Now a person like Jane looks for in-depth
analytics to be delivered to
her in a timely manner so that
she could then turn those insights
into business decisions.
The group that provides such analytics
to Jane are practitioners, in
this example, a person named John,
who works with our platform and
our applications on a daily basis.
In his role,
John processes a large volume
of data
and uses multiple tools
to turn that data into analytics
and insights and delivers that to
Jane and other business leaders.
In order to provide these analytics in a timely
manner, what John needs is scalable
infrastructure so that he can
process large volume of data
and provide timely insights.
In addition, there are also team members
in this example, Sarah, who perform
very deep research on
the analytics that we provide
through the platform and the application
as a starting point.
So her job is to analyze again
a very large volume of data
to draw insights that will
help Jane kind of build the
competitive edge in the marketplace
and similar to John.
Sarah also strives for,
you know, scalable infrastructure so that she can
process large volume of data and
turn them into insights.
So when teams that I just kind
of walked through, when they are looking to
advance their analytical capabilities and
figure out how to
kind of derive
advanced analytics out of large volume of data,
they look for solutions out in the market
and obvious solution that they land on
are data lakes where data lakes,
as most of you would know, uh,
provide all the scalable infrastructure,
the.
Flexibility in terms of the data, schemas
and all that where the data doesn't need to be
structured in a uh relational
database in order for John and Sarah to
take advantage of.
But as they are evaluating these data lakes
and try to implement that into
their ecosystem and
integrate that with their workflows, they
run into a slew of challenges.
A very common challenge that we see
is that the strategy that they apply
is, hey, let's build a data lake, let's
dump all the data into data lake, and users
will figure out
how to take advantage of that
product and get the insights delivered,
and that doesn't work very well in most cases.
In fact, we have seen examples after
examples
where that has not worked out very well.
One of our largest clients, uh,
actually spent 2 years building such
data lake capabilities, and
it has been over 1 year since that project concluded,
and unfortunately they are still not able
to take full advantage of such a data
lake. These are the challenges
that they run into, and we have seen
examples after examples where vanilla
data lake implementations struggle
to deliver the value that they promise.
This was our motivation to build
what we call the applied data lake or
risk data lake.
This data lake builds on the data lake
foundation, so it brings all the
benefits of the data lake,
everything from scalable infrastructure
to schema,
you know, flexibilities and so forth,
but in addition,
it also brings domain specific
organization of the data and represents the
data entities not just a series of integers
and strings, but rather
domain specific concepts such as portfolio,
policies, and locations,
the concepts that make sense in the risk
management arena. This
data lake also comes with built-in
analytical tools,
everything from drag and drop reporting capability
that we built using
Quicksight as well as ability to query
the data using SQL and
for more advanced users like Sarah that we
saw earlier
to be able to use programmable
notebooks to analyze data
and build
advanced analytics.
We integrated risk data lake with the intelligent risk
platform that I covered just a few slides ago.
And by doing so,
everyone on our client site, from Jane to
John and even Sarah, are
able to take advantage of this data lake,
use it
to develop and consume advanced
risk analytics.
So, in summary, what Risk
data lake is, is an extension
of the platform that we have built, which is called
Intelligent Risk Platform.
It comes with full integration with
the platform, meaning all the data that we have in
the platform is available in
Risk Data Lake.
In addition, it allows users to import
other data assets that they might want to
incorporate into
the analytics.
In terms of tools, it comes,
it covers an entire spectrum of analytical
tools from
reporting engine to ability to query
the data using SQL and programmable
notebooks with Python and R.
The drag and drop reporting functionality that
we built in Risk Data Lake
was built through AWS Quicksite. So
now let's look at how we did that.
So here is a screenshot of the
application that we built. This is an embedded
experience on the designer side.
Here you see kind of the core component
of our risk data lake which we call risk data
catalog,
where the data is cataloged as I mentioned earlier
in a You know, domain
with a domain context, so the data
assets that you see over there would make
sense to our end users,
and they kind of hide a lot of the
complexity of joining various data
elements to get to this level and
we build this kind of what we call visualization
ready data sets for
designers to be able to start with that
and turn them into
quick site analysis and dashboards.
Now, once the data is available
that way, using the embedded designer
experience that we built within our
application, designer can then
turn that into
various analysis and dashboards.
So if you think about John, our practitioner
that we saw earlier,
no longer needs to work with IT team
as Shaker was mentioning to to
kind of collect the data or turn that into a dashboard
only to then figure out, oh, now the
business users need a slight change to it
or want to slice and dice the data a different
way, right?
So in this example,
John would actually act as a
designer
and will design the dashboard as
he's getting
delivering that insight to
Jane, the business person.
And all this was made possible
thanks to the capabilities of Amazon Quick
Site. Now,
how did we implement this? So let's take a slightly
deeper dive into the steps we followed.
So as I mentioned, we have our
platform and persona centric
applications. All these applications write
their data into
the underlying common data
store that underpins the platform and
because we are on AWS,
uh, these are S3 buckets that we
have. Now we built
a risk data catalog on top
of this underlying data source,
and this is where we arrange the data
in a way that makes sense to our
end users.
But we didn't stop there. We added another layer
on top of it
to feed it into Quicksight. So
we built Quicksight data sets where
multiple
joints were performed on the RIS data
catalog to represent the data
in a ready to be visualized way.
And this is how the designers get access
to all the data sets and all
the underlying data for them to turn that into
dashboards and publish that for
the business consumption.
Now, as I said, we have hundreds of
clients
using our
platform and various applications, and
the way we deploy that is through a multi-tenancy
model. And so when we were integrating
Quicksight into our platform
and into Risk data lake,
we also had to figure out how to do
that for a multi-tenancy setup.
And as Shekhar mentioned, there were multiple
options that were available, and the one that
we chose was through the name space, and I'll
give you a bit more detail on that.
But yeah, so we have
quick site installation for every single
tenant out of 100s of tenants that we
have deployed
in production.
So, let's start how we did that. So each
tenant
gets a unique IM role corresponding
to a name space, as Shekhar mentioned, we,
we kind of took the name space approach.
Every namespace contains the tenant users
and security groups.
Access to all this data under
the tenant is controlled by the
security groups.
Now for quick site installation, we created
a logical folder that holds
all of the data sets.
The analysis that the designer
is building.
And all the dashboards and access
to this folder were controlled by
the security groups that I mentioned.
So now you replicate that in other
tenant where you would still be
able to kind of keep the names the same
like we didn't want to change the name of the data
sets from one tenant to another so
dashboards can become exchangeable
and so forth and we were able to achieve
that through this um
kind of deployment model.
Now, we didn't stop at just the tenant
level, we also had to implement low
level security.
So if you go back to the team that I was talking
about, John and Sarah
and even Jane for that matter
could have access to
different data assets within the
same tenant
because they belong to different business units or
other reasons.
And so we had to make sure that as a
designer is going into Relata Lake and
designing a dashboard or
a consumer like a business user is
accessing those dashboards, they can only
see the data that they have access to.
And the way we implemented this is
through the integration with the platform and this data
lake application we
pass the identity of the
user, whether it is a designer or a
consumer,
all the way down to Quicksight
and using Quicksight's row
level security feature in the data
sets that we deployed in Quicksight,
we are able to then implement
that security access layer
such that
users will only see the data that he or
she has access to.
Now think about this. Implementing such
granular access control in
a vanilla data lake would be
very, very difficult.
So this is how
we keep on adding more and
more value in RI data lake on
top of what the vanilla data lake
functionality provides you.
And again, this was made possible
because of the functionality available in Quicksight.
We deliver the entire quick site experience
in an embedded way. So what you are looking at
is our risk data lake application
where the designer experience is
fully embedded
within the application. So designers remain
in risk data lake application. They don't
have to go to a different application to
build the dashboard.
And once the designer published the dashboard,
the dashboard is made available to every single
application that we have in the platform.
So the applications that I mentioned earlier, Risk Modular
Treaty IQ 100 IQ.
Every single application gets all the
dashboards that were deployed
through Risk Data Lake.
And the reason for that is so the business users
Jane in our example
doesn't need to switch contexts, right? So she
is a regular user of RiskModeler,
which is our signature product, and
she can still remain in RiskModeler and
access all the dashboards that were built
through risk data lake application.
So this was very powerful and the reason,
one of the big reasons why we selected QuickSite
was because of their embeddability
not only on the consumption side but also
on the designer side
where we don't want John to go out and
talk to IT people and rely on them
to build those dashboards. He can act
as a designer
while still being in the application, build the dashboards
and publish them.
I hope this gives you an idea of what
we did it, how we did it, and why we
took this approach.
Now we are living in an era
where if I'm talking about some analytics
and I don't talk about Gen AI capability
it's kind of incomplete, right? So
where do we think kind of
are taking this functionality forward now
Shekhar already touched upon some of them that
those functionalities are some of them are available
already, but we have not integrated that into
our application. So our vision is
to start integrating them into
our application as we have built it.
So the very. First one is what we are gonna call
talk to the dashboard, right? So if you think
about the business persona who was
accessing all this dashboard,
imagine she's looking at a dashboard that
contains real critical
information with multiple worksheets and
and all that stuff. So while that
information is very valuable
at the end what she's interested in
is asking some questions and trying to figure
out what the answers are, and she can do
that by navigating through the dashboard or
imagine that she can just ask that question.
And the agent will basically
look at the dashboard, look at the underlying data,
and provide the answer.
If you take it one step further,
if you remember designer John,
what if he could build some of this
uh visualizations and dashboards
again by just
talking or uh in a natural language.
Such AI capabilities would be super
powerful and will revolutionize
how users develop and consume risk
analytics.
Risk data lake applications provide a
strong foundation for development of
such futuristic capabilities, and
we are looking forward to the partnership
with the AWS team.
To develop and integrate such capabilities.
Now, this data lake was launched
in October of this year, literally just
2 months ago.
And we started the journey of
integrating Quicksight into our
application in February of this year, so we
were able to
turn that around in a matter of months
and launch it as a
product offering.
And we are already seeing a lot of excitement
in the market.
This data lake with its current capabilities
and futuristic capabilities like what I just
covered
will democratize the risk analytics.
Like everyone from Jane to John and Sarah
will be able to not only process large
volume of data,
turn data into
analytics and insights, and
really achieve competitive edge in
the market.
In our industry that would mean
better risk selection, really understanding
what the impact of catastrophe is
into their exposure.
Jane, our business person, will be able to access
advanced risk analytics in a timely manner.
There are cases, especially when
they go through renewal cycles, they want
to consume more and more analytics, but
the time it takes to turn data into
insights is too long, especially
when the data is
too large. So she no longer needs to spin
up multiple
multi-year IT projects to make incremental
enhancements to her analytical
capabilities. She can rely on her team,
act as the designers to deliver these insights.
We are super excited about the future of risk
analytics and the role the risk data lake
and the intelligent
intelligent
risk platform will play in it.
The collaboration with the AWS team has
been amazing up to this point, and we
look forward to extending this partnership.
So with that, I'll pass it over to Jose
to cover the rest of it.
Good afternoon everyone.
Tough session after lunch
we need coffee probably.
So my name is Jose Banos. I'm a
quick sweet
go to market specialist worldwide specialist.
And
I brought this quote into the session and
uh
I would like to ask,
raise your hand, your hands if your
hand if you know who was uh
Charles Darwin.
I guess everybody, right?
Otherwise I would be in a problem in the trouble.
This is probably his most famous quote. It is
not the strongest species,
the one that survived,
neither the smartest one, but the
one with the most
capability to adapt to the environment.
And you might think,
what is the relationship between this and
Quick Sweet? Well,
think also about companies,
enterprise, corporations 50 years
ago. Big
corporations 40 years ago,
they probably are not around anymore or
not the leaders on the sector
even think about shorter time
10 years ago software services.
They are probably not anymore around. Why?
They were great. They were strong at that point, at
one point in time.
But maybe they were not able to adapt.
This is a timeline.
Of Quicksight.
Quicksight has been around approximately
a little bit between 8 to 9 years.
And there is a key
concept that you see through this
timeline.
Adding new functional functionalities.
And there is one reason why we can add new functionalities
constantly.
It's because the solid foundation
of Quicksight.
It allows us to release functionalities
almost every 2 weeks.
But there is another key concept here.
Working backwards. Have you heard about working
backwards?
I'm sure if you are working with Amazon, you have
heard about that.
90% of the features that we are
adding to the
Quick side and you will see that we are
at some point inter uh mixing
Quicksight with QuickSuite so 90%
of the functionalities in Quicksight they're
coming from you, from our customers,
from Moody's, from
all of our customers.
And that reflects our desire
to adapt to the needs of the market.
Our customers and of course we also have our
own roadmap,
but most of these functionalities are coming from
you. You can see if you look just at 2020
we were then using uh release a Quickset
Q. Providing NLQ
capabilities on our dashboards,
you were able in 2020 to ask
questions using natural language
to dashboard,
but then let's continue
thinking or working backwards.
What we have seen
and heard from our customers in the
last few, uh, couple of years.
They spend a lot of time
collecting data from multiple
locations using multiple analytics tools
that leading to a lack of
what is the right source
of truth.
Document system,
everything is kind of isolated.
There is no
uh consolidation in one
single place that leads into time consuming.
Time is wasted looking into
these different applications. There are teams
looking into one application, other teams
looking through other applications, and at the end they're
looking for the same information.
That is also leading to
longer time to take actions.
And today, you know, even, even our capacity
to stay focused has been reduced
over the time. I think today we can
stay like maybe 2-3 minutes focused on something,
so we need to take action
quickly, faster.
And the last one, which is probably my, my,
the one that I identify myself the most is the
routine tasks.
I hate it.
Raise your hand. Anybody here who likes to, for
example, Monday morning 9 a.m., you
have to populate an Excel with numbers or
something that is repetitive that is not
really useful.
Nobody's raising their hand obviously
so we prefer to focus on something that is
productive, something that is
more shiny,
exciting.
I, I, I'm a soccer player and uh
I will use that as an example. Uh, nobody would
like to be on the bench.
You want to be in the field. You want to be playing,
so that is
what what is happening with the traditional
way of of working.
And it translates into more than 40
hours
a month that we spend in
wasting time repetitive
tasks.
That's why QuickSuite
is
changing the way
that we understand the BI
traditional tools.
It's a truly agentic AI
that reimagines
the way we work in the.
IA era.
QuickSuite is the enabler
that combines data
and intelligent actions.
And I will walk you through this slide.
If you see on the bottom, we still need data.
AI is not going to work if we don't have data,
if we don't have quality of data.
You can see that we have enterprise data,
we have actions, and within the enterprise
data, we can have knowledge bases,
basically any type of unstructured data.
We can upload files also.
Audio files,
videos, PDFs,
Word docs,
any type of unstructured data.
And we can also use the quick sight data, structured
data. And we are adding this
concept of spaces.
Think about spaces like a storage.
Where you cannot only store data
in this case, where you can accept deliveries, let's
say in that way.
But through the actions you can also
interact with third party apps
so you can also send deliveries.
So our storage is going to be able to
store data but also send.
Data or action into third party
applications. And sometimes
our enterprise data is not enough. We need
to go out there,
go to the web, go to the LLMs,
Bedrock, uh, models
to enrich our
enterprise data.
Once we have that base, that,
uh, foundation layer.
Since we are working with data,
Governance and security is a very critical
aspect in our solutions.
We are
Using
Greek side.
Governance and data security
because it's reliable. We have been using it for 8 years
roll of security column level security,
uh, role permissions
and we are adding additional capabilities to
manage all the additional unstructured
data, uploading files, actions,
and so on.
So once we have our
governance and data, uh, layer we
have our
data foundation
we have the
capabilities. What are those capabilities?
Chat agents, research,
Quicksight flows and automate.
We want to democratize the access
to the insights.
What is the best way to democratize
the access to insights?
Having an easy tool.
A tool that anybody, no matter how
tech savvy you are,
you can use it,
and the best way is a chat.
Natural language
type a prompt type what you want
and ask for the question. Ask for the insight that
you're looking for.
That is the chat agent capabilities
access to any type of insight,
no matter what it is. I don't care anymore if it's
a structured or unstructured data.
I just want my insight.
Quicksight, we are still using Quicksight.
Quicksight is part of Quick Suite, so there are
times where we will need to access or
see because we are very visual, uh,
animals. That's true. We need to see a graph.
We need to see a chart so you can still
use Quicksight.
And research.
Think about the research for a more
or deep dive deep analysis.
Think about a report like a benchmark
benchmark analysis.
More professional format like when you have a
consultancy company coming to your
uh company to do a benchmark analysis
of one of your products or you want to go to market
with a with a product or
that is what research is gonna help you with
and I will I will talk a little bit more about that later
on. So
this is helping with the insights
with the data,
but I mentioned before that one of the things that I
hate the most is repetitive task routine
flows and automate those
are focusing on tackle
this problem
flows is gonna help you to.
Avoid this repetitive day to day task
like when you have to
look into the dashboard, find some outliers,
for example, and do something with those
outliers later on in another tool
you can,
you can automate that through uh the flows
and in those cases where you need to
interact with multiple agents with multiple
departments, automate is gonna
be the solution and I will go through this
in a little bit more later on.
But since we are talking about BI
or I guess most of us are coming from
the BI world,
let me walk you, walk you through
the
journey from self-serving BI
into uh AI
assisted BI
traditionally what we do.
We ask the customer, OK, what are the
questions that you want to
ask to the data?
And from there we find where is the data
and we build the dashboard and there is a unidirectional
communication from
the users and the dashboard
and this is uh
something that we need to continue to be working on
because the dashboard needs to be updated.
So what we are doing now, moving into
the next generation of BI with
agentic AI.
Is combining the data creating
this layer which here is in the middle
and before it was the bottom layer
where we are where we are combining
structure unstructured near real
time data
and we need to uh keep in mind also
that uh one of the uh probably
strongest or most uh.
Areas that I think is going to be changing
in the future for the good is the MCP
connection to third party data.
So we have the
single source of data, let's say that,
and then we move into how to interact
with that data.
Chat flows research automate I mentioned
those before, but
let's go even beyond that.
Add these capabilities into some of
the applications that we use more commonly
Outlook,
Slack, uh, Word, even in your
browser you can install or
add an add on into your browser
so you can,
uh,
add the chat and interact with your with your browser
with the content of the whatever is the web,
uh, that you are the browser that you're loading into a browser
so. Then
going back into the dashboard quicks side,
what we are doing is not only
not allowing only the users to
get inside but also directly
from the dashboard being able to
take actions.
From the data itself in the dashboard,
connect or send an action to a third party
application. So you need you don't need to to leave the dashboard.
I was telling you before about the quick
research and uh
think about quick research
you have as a company you have launched several
services to the market several products to the market.
And you want to launch a new one so you have a
history of data
about
marketing campaigns, what you did,
what was working well, what was working not that
well, the outcome in the
structure data showing you the sales
increase sales go down, whatever
so quick research is gonna use all that data
plus data that is in the foundational models
and if you want also data from the
Internet, from the web.
To create this
professional report with citations so you know
where from each data
is coming from so there is
let's say no risk or lower
risk to hallucination because you know where
is the data coming from.
Flows I mentioned before helping
with your day to day task.
I was talking with one customer,
uh, in the telco industry.
They were using a flow just to check
through the
call records from one month,
find outliers,
and, uh, the outliers detected
compared with the previous
2-3 months average consumption
and in case that there was like a 50%.
Uh,
or the consumption was 50% over the average
automatically
trigger and create a thick in Jira.
So that's one example of one simple
flow that you can,
uh, create with quick flows.
Quicker to make it's a little bit more
complex because it requires a little
more technical
knowledge
and uh
think about it as a
more.
Multi-agent
cooperation where you can even
even include some steps with
a Python code to be executed.
And one example would be
uh human resources
department where you want to uh
Add new users into the system and you know
you need to work with multiple, multiple,
uh,
areas of databases and so on to
add that user.
To summarize,
What we are doing with Quicksight and now Quick Suite
is providing insight for everybody,
everyone. You don't
need to be a tech savvy as I mentioned before
because it's an easy tool to use
basically you just need to type what you want to do
even when we I was talking about flows
you can build a flow
literally telling I want a flow
that is doing this, this and that
just describing the different
multiple steps.
Unlock new business values as Moody's
shared today
with us
how they are embedding Quicksight
into their intelligent risk platform, helping
their customers to do better decisions.
And the last one
Answers into action. I just mentioned
about I just talked about this previously
directly from the dashboard when you detect something
when there is an insight that is critical
or is uh
uh important to highlight,
you can send that information into a third party.
With that,
if you have more
interest in knowing a little bit more,
you can scan this QR code. You
can go to the QuickSite embedded Quick Suite,
but I will
highlight this, uh,
one on my on the left of the
slide, the Quicksight community.
Because it contains
all the information that you need,
literally,
there is a YouTube channel with, uh, videos.
There is a section for Q&A.
There are webinars that we
run every week,
workshops that we run monthly. Everything
is here, even myself,
and I have been working with Quicksight for 4.5
years. I go to the Q&A sometimes
when I have questions
because we have a community of people also
helping to answer,
uh, questions.
We're Thursday so probably there is only one
more session before uh before
the end of the day
and to end I would like to.
Ask or share something with you. I have 6 more
minutes. Do you know
Bernard Boggles?
Anybody knows here who is Bernard Bogos?
Yeah, he's AWS CTO.
Uh, uh, in fact, his
keynote is gonna be in around one hour, so
I highly recommend if you have time to join.
If you go to his LinkedIn and you can go to
to
to LinkedIn right now on your phone if you have a if
you want to.
In his background on the LinkedIn,
he has one quote that says
the most dangerous
sentence in English
is
we have always done things on this
way. I love
it. I love it.
Because If you're doing
things in a way today and they work, it doesn't
mean that you cannot do things better.
There are more things that you can explore.
So I will
end my session, encourage you.
If you haven't
tried yet Quick Sue,
try. Even if you
need to reach out to us, you need credits,
you need to reach out to us.
And I'm sure you will
like it. With
that, uh, please
complete the session survey, and
I think we have some time for, for
questions as well, so
I will ask my colleagues to
come back to the stage and.